bastien sont appelés à se prononcer sur
l'avenir institutionnel de l'alsace une
grande consultation populaire via
internet a été lancée aujourd'hui par
brigitte klinkert et frédéric bierry les
présidents des deux départements
il propose la création d'une
collectivité unique d'alsace à statut
particulier
une opportunité à saisir pour les élus
dans un contexte favorable puisque le
premier ministre a chargé le préfet de
la région à d'un rapport sur l'évolution
de l'alsace reportage nadine lit et
nicolas meyer c'est un pas de plus vers
une alsace unis brigitte klinkert et
frédéric bierry côte à côte pour
annoncer leur volonté de fusionner le
haut-rhin et le bas-rhin
objectif créer une collectivité unique
d'alsace
cinq ans après le fiasco du référendum
les alsaciens sont à nouveau invités à
se prononcer sur la question
cette fois pas de bulletin mais un site
internet pour livrer son avis et ses
propositions 1 millions de formulaires
papier seront également distribués
certes la consultation n'aura pas de
valeur juridique mais elle pourra peser
sur les négociations en cours avec
l'état et la grande région
on est à un moment décisif où il ya une
écoute du gouvernement c'est donc une
occasion unique pour les alsaciens
de livrer leur expression parce que le
projet que nous déposerons au préfet au
premier ministre avec brigitte klinkert
ce sera un projet qui sera enrichie
justement des réflexions et plus les
alsaciens seront nombreux à s'exprimer
plus nous aurons de poids pour porter
cette démarche d'évolution à l'échelle
nationale l'état a fixé des limites pas
question de sortir du grand test pour
autant les élus alsaciens revendique une
collectivité forte avec des compétences
élargies l'économie le tourisme la
coopération transfrontalière ou encore
le bilinguisme mais il faudra aussi
convaincre le président du grand test to
tell à 5 il est pas sûr qu jean rottner
voit d'un très bon oeil ce transfert
massif de compétences pour l'instant
nous attendons de le rencontrer nous
avons eu beaucoup beaucoup des changes
que ce soit avec le président de la
république avec le premier ministre avec
le président de l'assemblée nationale le
président du sénat tout le monde se rend
compte qu'il faut faire quelque chose
rentrer en alsace et je pense que j'en
reconnais rossi devra bien prendre en
compte cette demande des alsaciennes et
des alsaciens les alsaciens ont jusqu'à
fin juin pour donner leur avis date à
laquelle le projet des élus sera
communiqué au gouvernement